c'est un geste millénaire le trait l'art
du trait c'est là où sur mon dessin va
apparaître des pieds et la grande croix
ici l'art du trait ou stéréotomie c'est
la base du métier du compagnon
charpentier
il dessine sur une épure à plat toutes
les données de son oeuvre en trois
dimensions traduire sur papier ce qu'il
conçoit nos son cerveau ap arsenal
dassin en fait construire l'édifice on
offre ou même le bâtiment c'est comme ça
que travaillaient les bâtisseurs de
cathédrales au moyen-âge ceux qui ont
construit notre dame de paris au 12e
siècle
c'est avec le gothique que laura a
vraiment pris son essor en france
tailleur de pierre maçons et
charpentiers ceux qui ont construit ce
qu'on a appelé la forêt la charpente de
la cathédrale de san mames mètres de
long ni dessinée ça au sol frais grande
échelle mais après ils posaient les
morceaux de bois par dessus est pur il
coupait italia il assemble et ses
bâtisseurs c'était des compagnons qui
travaillait sous la direction d'un
maître qui était lui-même un compagnon
comme patrick moore il est le seul
compagnon charpentier du devoir du tour
de france c'est comme ça qu'il s'appelle
le sol est unique à être originaire d
amérique
née et élevée dans le nord de l'ontario
il fait des études de charpentier et un
jour il rencontre au québec un aspirant
compagnon français qui lui explique tout
et il décide
oui c'est ça en fait je veux devenir
compagnon ça c'est pour les charpentiers
il est adopté comme aspirant à dijon
comment son tour de france change de
chantier deux fois par an surtout dans
la restauration du patrimoine
au bout de trois ans il est reçu comme
compagnon par les anciens il reçoit l'as
cannes avec sur le pommeau sa nouvelle
identité mort patrick pendanx de
province canadien mon nom compagnonnique
l'ami du trait ensuite seulement grande
titre compagnon pas sans charpentier du
devoir bon drilles de tour de france
ensuite ici c'était reçus à tour pour la
saint joseph en 2013
et voilà son chef-d'oeuvre ce très tôt
d'une très grande complexité qu'il a
présentée aux anciens pour s'arrêter
pion l'autre à côté il l'a fait pour
s'amuser
cela ça représente à 450 heures de
travail elle seule la sarre à présent
six cent cinquante ans ce sont
maintenant des pièces de musée qui ont
voyagé de france au québec et iront
prochainement au japon
patrick molle travaillent sur des
chantiers mais surtout dans son atelier
de la région d'ottawa il enseigne l'art
du trait à des élèves venus du monde
entier
ce sont leurs maquettes le résultat de
leur travail comme tout le monde ils
déplorent l' incendie de notre dame
mais pour des gens de métier comme lui
la suite représente une aubaine
extraordinaire surtout pour les
charpentiers intérieur de pierre
couvreur
c'est vraiment une rave chance et de
rêves ça te faire reconstruire une
cathédrale
aujourd'hui c'est ça se fait pas ça le
débat à paris maintenant c'est faut-il
reconstruire à l'identique en bois de
chêne à ces époques là ils utilisaient
des outils et la matériel aussi moderne
que possible et donc peut-être dans cet
esprit là on peut faire moderne et
peut-être l'identique mois par seulement
amoureux de la patrimoine
je dirais à l'identique la charpente de
la nef de notre dame est classique
relativement simple quoique monumentale
mais pour la flèche est différent celle
qui a brûlé conçu par viollet le duc au
19e siècle était essentiellement une
oeuvre de charpente recouverte très
complexe en chaîne s'il fallait
reconstruire à l'identique les
compagnons ont déjà une longueur
d'avancé
patrick nous signale qu'une maquette de
la flèche a été réalisé en 1970 par
trois compagnons charpentiers danger en
touraine les bâtisseurs de cathédrales
sont encore parmi nous ils ont des
héritiers et des jeunes
patrick moore n'a que 34 ans croient